dak is always going to say all the right
things he's under contract for this year
at 31.4 million dollars next year
the cowboys can tag him again the price
increases to
37.68 million my guess is if they apply
the tag he'll take it and he'll stay for
one more year but do you think he wants
to be with the cowboys both now and in
the future
boy have we ever heard that before the
only player i've i ever remember wanting
out of dallas was dwayne thomas if you
remember way back when you and i are are
old enough to remember dwayne thomas but
players want to come to dallas they
don't want to they don't want to leave
dallas i mean you look at jamal adams
and ja davion clowney and everybody else
whenever a guy goes up on the trade
block or is a free agent oh he's going
to go to dallas and jerry always thinks
he's going to get all these star players
and they all want to come to dallas and
now we're talking about a guy does he
want to be here i don't know why you
wouldn't want to be in dallas you can
make more money
outside of football being in dallas than
any anywhere else in in the nfl and so
there's a lot of money to be had playing
as the quarterback of the dallas cowboys
and a lot of jobs after football we've
seen with troy aikman and tony romo and
don meredith and everybody who's come
before those guys uh has gone on to have
great careers after football i do think
he wants to be in dallas but i am
surprised that they don't already have a
long-term contract and so it does create
questions of where this thing is headed
and how quickly if when they get a
contract done
i think this is less about dak wanting
to be a cowboy or not wanting to be a
cowboy and more about dak wanting a
contract that fairly compensates him for
what he's done in the past when he was
getting peanuts in comparison and
where he is now and i've said this all
along the cowboys have taken advantage
of every aspect of the cba to allow them
to not pay dac very much money to get
him last year for two million dollars to
resist signing to a contract at least
the contract he wanted and now they've
activated the highest level of the
franchise tag they went with the
exclusive version 31.4 million the math
is very simple he makes 69.08 million
over the next two years and then comes
the kirk cousins decision do they go
transition tag at 45 million plus do
they go franchise tag at 54 million plus
do they let him become a free agent in
2022 and i think dak
until they give him something that
causes him to say i'll trade in the
rights that you have given me under the
franchise tag he's going to continue to
play it out you know he could become a
free agent in 2022 and still resign with
the cowboys he doesn't have to leave he
could take less than he could have a
team out there that offers him 10
million a year more than the cowboys are
offering and he could choose to stay in
dallas so i just think he's playing it
out one year at a time he understands
most of these contracts are one year at
a time who cares if you have a 12-year
deal or a six-year deal or a five-year
deal it's only guaranteed to the extent
that it's guaranteed period so i i think
that's what he's doing i don't think
it's about not wanting to play for the
cowboys i think it's about wanting to be
treated fairly and wanting to get
himself to a point where he has maximum
flexibility on what his decisions will
be about where he plays
mike how big of a gamble is this though
by dak prescott considering the
economics and where we're headed with
this revenue shortfall how big of a
gamble do you think this is by dak
by going year to year
well how big of a gamble is it for the
cowboys by letting them go year to year
i mean here's the thing and somebody was
making this point last week to me before
the deadline for doing a long-term deal
came and went
why do you think the argument was made
that the cowboys will tag him again next
year why do you think the cowboys or
anyone else would pay him 37.68 million
next year the answer is easy the cowboys
already are paying him 31 for this year
they could have gone with the lower
franchise tag they could have saved four
or five million bucks this year and all
they would have given up was the
possibility that someone would come in
sign them through an offer sheet that
they couldn't or wouldn't match and
they'd get two first-round picks as
compensation they weren't interested in
saving the four or five million and
taking that risk that tells me they want
him now maybe they could change their
mind over the course of the next year
but what are they going to do at
quarterback if they don't have dak
prescott they got lucky when they found
dak prescott in 2016. and maybe the fact
that they've done a pretty good job
drafting players in recent years will
give them
the hubris to believe that they'll go
out and find another starting
quarterback who can come right in in
2021 maybe that's what they'll do but
i i think that yeah look i i
here's another way to answer your
question
we don't know what the market would bear
for dak prescott we don't know whether
another team would pay dak prescott
because the cowboys have prevented him
from ever finding out prevented us from
finding out so i don't know what the
gamble is because the cowboys feel
strongly enough about him to force him
to stay
well and and he's going to stay he's
going to stay a cowboy i think jerry
jones will get this deal done at some
point but i know he's surprised i
guarantee he's surprised if you go back
you remember the start of the season and
i got jerry after a game and i asked him
about dak and he said a deal is imminent
well
he obviously had a different definition
of imminent than dak prescott in his
camp had because here we sit
almost a year later and there's still
not a deal done and i think the cowboys
are shocked that dill's not done at this
point
and on the point that that uh dak
prescott can make much more money off
the field in dallas than he can anywhere
else
i did have someone point out to me last
week when that issue came up
quincy carter and chad hutchinson did
not make any money off the fiancee
you have to win
yeah you have to be good right you can't
be bad if you're a bad cowboys
quarterback you're not getting any
endorsements but the bar is lower if
you're good and you do set the table to
get yourself into a broadcast booth when
your career ends but that's one thing
dak has been consistent about shireen he
doesn't care about that he look and and
i view it from his perspective
he came in as a fourth-round draft pick
he saved their butts in 2016 when tony
romo all of a sudden couldn't play
and he started every game for four
seasons and when the window opened on
their opportunity to sign him to a new
contract they dragged their feet they
low-balled him they didn't want to
reward him for what he'd done they
didn't want to pay him what he thought
he should get
and so i give him credit he has been
as determined and as resolute as any
player i can ever remember
to get what what he thinks he deserves
and he's willing to roll the dice it
reminds me a lot of joe flacco when joe
flacco in in august of 2012 rejected the
offer that the ravens made unless on a
second contract he bet on himself and it
paid off for him with an
a super bowl mvp championship and a
gigantic contract and it's paying off in
a different way for dak he got 31.4
million i mean no matter what else
happens
this year or next year or beyond that
for dak prescott he got a raise from 2
million to 31.4 million from one year to
the next that's that's not a bad
increase in a year to year salary
well you talk about being resolute
you know the cowboys always think they
can get these deals done because they
talk to the player they get the player
on the phone and say hey here's the
reasons we need to do this here's what
we're offering etcetera etcetera
and they tried to do that with dak and
dak was smart enough to call todd france
and say
okay let's wait a minute here i'm i'm
not getting on the phone with you guys
by myself and and doing this by myself i
have an agent uh for for reasons to get
this done so uh he is holding out for
what he thinks he's worth and and kudos
to him for for doing what he thinks is
right and getting the money he thinks he
deserves
and when getting them on the phone
doesn't work you get them on the bus and
you break out the johnny walker blue and
then you try to get to get a signature
on paper to the extent the person can
can write his own name at the time uh
they they finally work out a deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports